now we wanted to highlight a very
important town hall happening tomorrow
from life
aid voice project the town hall thursday
at 2 45 pm at the ahern hotel
the focus is to bring together leaders
from the military entertainment and
sports communities
to build bridges with law enforcement
and improve the safety of our community
life aid research institute founder and
chairman john warden talked about the
goal of
local improvement so the voice project
is about veterans
out improving communities every day and
how can
the veteran experience the life
experience that they gain from iraq and
afghanistan and other places
combined with entertainment and sports
build build a bridge between law
enforcement
and the community they serve to improve
the community and strengthen the
community
in our chat warden also talked about
other communities they held a town hall
and
tangible examples of progress including
working on community policing in los
angeles with lapd and members of the
dodgers
and then taking on anti-bias training in
arlington texas
with police the military and the
department of justice
i mean just think about the life
experience and we have a
you know obviously we have the event
tomorrow with las vegas pd
and we have some great community voices
that are going to be participating from
the naacp
to some of the local faith community the
business community the education
community
and of course law enforcement tomorrow's
town hall will include metro police our
faith community has mentioned business
leaders veterans elected officials even
the raiders
you can register here to join tomorrow's
event virtually the link is on our
website eight news now dot com